[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
choix dit ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro le sommaire de ce jeudi 6
juin l'île de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines accueille une exposition qui
interroge la mobilité une coréalisation
entre chercheurs et groupes de citoyens
à découvrir jusqu'au 26 juillet 14 % de
la population française était à troyan
2018 que vous en fassiez partie ou non
vous pouvez découvrir cet univers lors
de la toute première convention
tatouages des yvelines
à leur arrivée à mantes-la-jolie ses
samedis et dimanches 8 et 9 juin le
festival escales d'ailleurs revient à
plaisir des concerts de la danse des
expositions seront un point sur le
programme avec l'élue à la culture de la
ville interrogé nos mobilité c'est
l'objectif de l'exposition trajectoire
réalisée par des chercheurs et des
groupes de citoyens
une exposition elle-même mobile elle
tourne dans toute l'île de france et
fait un arrêt du 27 mai au 26 juillet à
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
reportage réalisé avec océane bazire
qu'elle soit individuelle collective au
mondial les trajectoires façonnent nos
sociétés et nos histoires
une thématique prise à son sens large
pour une exposition ludique et
interactive à l'objectif de cette
exposition c'est d'interroger les gens
c'est de mobiliser un peu
leurs questionnements sur qu'est-ce que
c'est se déplacer qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que c'est vivre dans une ville
et dans quel monde vit-on
et quels sont les impacts de la cedh et
de tous ses déplacements à l'échelle de
notre planète découvrir la mobilité de
son corps à l'aide d'une balance qui
identifie le point reposant sur chacune
de ses jambes ou bien les trajectoires
des mots et du langage
mais alors on fait dans cet extrait ci
vous avez l'oreille vous avez peut-être
entendu le mot mayonnaise qui a été
incorporé dans la langue japonaise
l'exposition entre dans le projet
question société et enjeux citoyens de
la région ile de france
elle restitue des travaux de chercheurs
mais aussi de groupes de citoyens en
collaboration avec huit associations de
médiation scientifique une par
département la médiation scientifique en
fait c'est l'idée de pouvoir apporter
aux citoyens
le maximum d'informations sur des
questions de science pour qu'ensuite ils
puissent faire leurs propres choix
construire leur propre opinion
ouverte au grand public les mercredi et
samedi puis du lundi au vendredi à
partir des vacances scolaires vous
pourrez même y planter votre fleur de
mobilité à chaque pétale une
caractéristique de vos propre
trajectoire et ensuite je suis invité à
la pause et là où j'ai envie d'aller
je vais la mettre pour cette fois oh
on you que je me trompe pas au japon si
ça rentre voilà et avant de partir au
japon pouvait circuler à l'espace
exposition de l'île de loisirs les
vestiaires de l'ancienne piscine ont
même été utilisé pour y découvrir
l'infographie et photographies de la
musique latine des déambulations de la
danse africaine une exposition sur la
pologne vous allez pouvoir voyager dans
le parc du château de plaisir ce samedi
18 juin nous a rejoint en plateau
philippe korda vous êtes maire adjoint à
la culture à plaisir bonjour bonjour
marienne alors pour commencer une
question très simple
le festival escales d'ailleurs qu'est ce
que c'est écoutez on a la chance déjà
depuis 17 ans puisque on en est la 17ème
édition de proposer aux plaisirs ou à
leur famille à leurs amis de se
regrouper autour du parc du château pour
passer une superbe journée d'invitation
au voyage de la découverte des cultures
du monde en partenariat bien sûr avec
nos associations locales pour une
journée vraiment de festive et de
découverte vraiment culturel alors j'ai
cité quelques exemples c'est assez
éclectique le programme est riche
comment vous organisez tout ça écoutez
c'est du travail quand même puisque même
si on est rodé maintenant on a un cadre
assez précis c'est plus d'un an de
recherche des artistes des des idées
pour toujours garder quelques valeurs
sûres que les plaisirs wa attendent ils
ont leurs pôles bien précis qu'ils
veulent retrouver mais aussi des
nouveautés
vraiment on cherche toujours à les
surprendre avec quelque chose qu'ils ne
connaissent pas des concerts de là
dedans semaine de la gastronomie c'est
là
oui en fait on a un paul ii va dire une
scène classique où on pose des artistes
de grande qualité
cette année ce sera goran bregovic qui
est la tête de fiche bien connu pour le
rock un peu des balkans très original on
a bien sûr un pôle danse ou là ce sont
plutôt les associations locales qui font
les démonstrations de leur travail de
l'année
on a un pôle jeux pour les enfants
ouvert tout l'après-midi ce sont des
jeux qu'ils n'ont pas l'habitude de voir
en bois très grand avec un petit peu de
prises dans l'espace voilà ils sont
vraiment ravi aussi et puis dans la cour
des communs du château on est là sur une
représentation artistique un peu plus de
proximité
ambiance fête au village et tout ça bien
sûr en pouvant se restaurer auprès des
stands proposés par nos associations
culturelles alors cette année il a une
saveur un peu particulière
est-ce que c'est toujours dans le parc
du château mais il a été rénové nous
attendait peut-être un peu plus de monde
oui alors c'est sûr que quand on vient
dans le parc du château par l'entrée
côté ville côté église c'est clair que
les plaisirs roi vont pouvoir découvrir
pour ceux qui n'ont pas eu la chance de
participer à l'inauguration
la nouvelle porte le nouveau portail
face à l'église le mur réhabiliter et
puis surtout toutes les plantations
refaites un petit peu à l'esprit de
l'époque et donnant une perspective
magnifique sur ce château est donc dans
cet esprit festif ce sera magnifique
on va on est un peu sur l'historique
pourquoi un tel événement à plaisir
alors en fait notre mère joséphine
colmate berger qui était à l'époque
adjointe à la culture a proposé que
l'ensemble des quartiers qui sont assez
répartis sur la commune se réunissent au
sein du parc du château que beaucoup ne
connaissaient pas forcément là qu'ouvert
au public et l'idée c'était de
s'investir les uns les autres dans une
proposition d' échanges culturels et
d'année en année ça a pris un petit peu
d'ampleur ça s'est renforcé sur le plan
artistique et c'est devenu maintenant un
incontournable très attendue de nouveaux
plaisirs mois quand on dit dix mille
visiteurs attendus vous mettez même en
place des navettes depuis la gare de
plaisir grignon
oui bon an mal an chaque année on est à
peu près de dix mille personnes dix
mille visiteurs c'est vrai que pour ceux
qui viennent de la gare routière où
train des navettes gratuites toutes les
heures sont proposés donc renseignez
vous bien auprès de du site de la ville
vous avez sur le programme les horaires
des navettes
ça permet vraiment à tout le monde de
nous rejoindre en toute simplicité pour
passer une belle journée et dernière
question
on espère qu'à une bonne météo mais je
crois vous avez une bonne étoile à ce
sujet
oui alors on en plaisante un peu et on
croise toujours les doigts c'est vrai
que chaque année il fait beau le jours
d'escale d'ailleurs là on a eu un peu de
pluie on sait qu'on aura un petit coup
de vent demain
mais samedi le soleil sera au rendez
vous bon bah c'est ce qu'on vous
souhaite en tout cas merci philippe
korda devenu sur notre plateau merci
beaucoup alors escale d'ailleurs c'est
ce samedi 8 juin de 14h30 à 23h30 veut
retrouvez toute la programmation sur le
site internet de la ville au ciné cette
d'elancourt lubbock en a ramené des
pellicules du festival de cannes c'est
votre brique dans les selles
saint-quentinoise
[Musique]
cette semaine aussi 17,2 très beau film
ici de la compétition d'ailleurs pas que
de la compétition cannoise ce très beau
72e festival de cannes
un festival réputé très dense et très
riche effectivement donc le premier
c'est sybille qui est un thriller
français de justin triais avec virginie
efira qui est en train de devenir une
star qui est déjà une star et adèle
exarque populeuse qui a été découverte
dans les films de talent de kechiche ou
à annoncer je vais pas raconter
l'histoire c'est assez intense assez
bouleversant c'est l'histoire d'une scie
qui va devenir romancière et qui en tant
qu actrice qui va s'approprier son
histoire c'est assez vertigineux et
c'est à découvrir donc on sale au ciné
cette semaine le film est sorti la
semaine dernière est le deuxième fils
c'est le jeune dame est alors le jeune
ahmed prix du scénario pour les frères
dardenne à cannes
encore une fois un très très beau film
très prenant très bouleversant ça
raconte l'histoire d'un jeune garçon qui
s'appelle ahmed qui a 13 ans et qui est
tiraillé on va dire entre les lé désir
de pureté de son image et parce qu'il
est très religieux et l'a dit donc à
découvrir dans nos salles cette semaine
aussi 17
[Musique]
une plongée dans la custom culture avec
la toute première convention tatouages
des yvelines
c'est ce que vous propose l'association
ouest motors 78 à mantes-la-jolie ses 8
et 9 juin 44 eur seront présents pour
vous faire découvrir leurs univers et
leurs styles différents
les plus téméraires pourront même se
faire un prénom et un souvenir
indélébile ou un tatouage éphémère pour
les indécis mais le wes moteur tu as
tout chaud ce n'est pas que des
tatouages jérémy dal bello nous a
présenté l'événement la kustom kulture
en fait c'est un univers à part entière
donc ça recoupe la musique avec des
concerts sept groupes au total qui vont
vous du rock et du rockabilly dans tout
le week-end et il le samedi soir il y
aura foule barber c'est un artiste
eurocks été révélée par the voice qui
sera présent et puis les concerne donc
le samedi le dimanche et avec ça des
expositions en fait exposition autos et
motos présente avec des préparateurs des
concessionnaires et des artisans aussi
qui sont présents vous commencez à
connaître le moule qui ce jeud adresse
finlandais qui mixtent pétanque et
stratégies le jeu de vos vacances d'été
a fait du chemin et sort des campings il
existe même une fédération depuis 2013
qui organise chaque année un open de
france du maul qui cependant pas besoin
de licence le moule qui restent en jeu
innovant sport que l'on peut tout de
même pratiquée au club
aujourd'hui la france compte plus
d'associations de molky que la finlande
elle même nicolas d'andré a rencontré
celle des clayes-sous-bois lors d'une
journée portes ouvertes pour laquelle
les amateurs sont venus de toute l'île
de france
j'ai attiré aussi quelques quelques
boulistes du club d'à côté qui était qui
s'interrogeait de savoir comment on joue
au môle qui donc on a quelques uns qui
sont revenus enchantés donc on va
essayer de créer aussi un partenariat
sur la ville pour faire d action commun
l'avantagé du maul qui sur la pétanque
c'est que il ya un peu de stratégie
parce qu'il ya des points à marquer il
faut pas dépasser un certain nombre
d'hommes plus et c'est compliqué quoi
voir c'est plus compliqué direction
paris pour parler informatique
[Musique]
alan turing mathématicien anglais à qui
l'on doit le l'ancêtre de l'ordinateur
est incarnée sur scène la pièce la
machine de turing récompensé quatre fois
aux molières 2010 9 se joue jusque fin
décembre au théâtre saint michel dans le
8e arrondissement de paris reportage de
miles 3 de nos confrères via grand paris
c'est l'histoire d'alan turing un homme
qui a changé le monde un mathématicien
anglais qui a créé l'ancêtre de
l'ordinateur pour percer le secret de la
machine enigma
[Musique]
utilisée alors par les allemands pour
communiquer leurs tactiques de guerre
avez vous fait pendant la guerre
monsieur turing je te présente énigmes
en ce four d'hitler est en train de me
précipiter vers une seconde guerre
mondiale turing est cet engin là risque
de nouvelles pertes
mais cette pièce parle avant tout de la
vie privée d'un génie j'ai voulu mettre
en avant sa vie parce que déjà je
trouvais que rendre un génie proches
humain attachant
c'était importance tout son travail
était sous le sceau du secret pendant
des années mais il ya une biographie qui
a été sorti en 1983 qui s'appelle
l'énigme de l'intelligence il ya eu un
film que beaucoup de gens ont vu qui
s'est vraiment focalisé sur la
cryptanalyse d'enigma après le film le
pardon royal la réhabilitation et donc
les archives qui ressurgissent et c'est
la somme de toutes ces informations que
j'ai prises pour écrire mon histoire il
se suicidera en croquant une pomme plein
de cyanure après avoir subi la
castration chimique pour son
homosexualité
une mise en scène de mathieu delfau avec
un fond de vidéo qui plonge le
spectateur dans ce chemin de vie hors du
commun
elle est composée en partie d' images
d'archivés de vrais desseins de vraie
équation de vraies lettres manuscrites
de turing et puis aussi des photos que
je suis allé prendre moi-même en
angleterre à cambridge notamment où il a
étudié à blutch les parcs où il a décodé
l'enigma et puis il ya des photos même
de cette maison à manchester perdu dans
la campagne où il a vécu et où il est
mort que j'ai retrouvé donc je suis allé
me promener dans tous ces endroits et
entre eux les archives les dessins tout
ça on a créé cette espèce de de puzzle
visuel d'équations qu'il qui raconte
aussi turing la pièce qui a gagné quatre
molières en 2019 est à découvrir jusqu'à
fin décembre au théâtre michel
c'est la fin de votre 7,8 choisir merci
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour de nouvelles
idées sorties
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
ouais